[Music]
the Jumanji remake okay yeah are you
looking forward to seeing my honestly
didn't even Vicki so much I didn't know
that do you have anything I have much
that I haven't been reached out to be in
it would you say yes if they were like
hey would you make a cameo probably no I
would definitely do something in that if
they wanted me to Kirsten Dunst weighing
in on the rocks Jumanji her directorial
debut and why she couldn't stop laughing
on the set of the beguile I read that
you and Al Fanning just became the
closest of friends and you actually said
that she was a soul mate
I think that you know throughout life
you meet certain people that you just
connect with instantly and she you know
immediately if we were together doing
these interviews we've just been
giggling the whole time which is
ridiculous but she is she brings out the
like eighteen year old it's awful she's
so funny q than I love her I hope you
like apple pie is that my recipe it is
was it hard than to keep a straight face
during some of those scenes I think of
apple pie scenes we had such a little
shorthand connection with each other so
I could just look at Ellen she burst out
laughing you're set to direct her sister
Dakota in the bell jar is that in
production yet not yet we're in a
rewrite right now and hopefully we'll be
raring to go within this year or early
next year what prompted your decision to
to get into directing Dakota was
actually the one that approached me to
do this with her oh wow I didn't know
that was it just an immediate yes yes I
mean it was you know it was one of my
favorite books growing up and yeah of
course yeah and your fiancee of course
is set to be in the movie as well so how
is that gonna work if you're like a can
he has a cameo so it's not like he's I'm
lucky to have him in the movie you've
worked with Sophia for about 20 years
now going all the way back to the Virgin
Suicides so what's evolved or changed
in that period of time between you guys
well I when I was 16 I looked up to
Sophia as an older sister on this film
it felt the most you know like a
friendship so I feel like we're equals
now that was my first movie where it was
like I was allowed to be sexual to be
honest and I was lucky because it was
handled with a female director and done
very classy and done because I was a
very innocent 16 year old I was oh
stuff that like I was not jumping on
Josh Hartnett in a car like all these
crazy things which I was very nervous
you know I was very innocent and she you
know it was such a beautiful film and
yeah it was it it was the best like
coming-of-age kind of role I could have
asked for so then when you go into this
movie and you have that intimate scene
with Colin Farrell
yeah Sophia was more embarrassed than I
was she was like blushing in the corner
it's like making your sister make out
with someone well actually we didn't not
kiss that was part of the dynamical I
want it to be a little more lustful and
aggressive rather than you know it
wasn't that way yeah
you